how much have things changed the last 20
years
everything's changed everything so about
24 years ago i wrote uh to my friends an
email saying online video is gonna be tv
and so i'm gonna head to online video
right now because i'm positive that it's
this is in the 90s when aol is a thing
yeah 98 i wrote the email and what was
the foresight how did you even know that
that was going to be a thing this is
before youtube yeah so
i i'd like to think that i'm a logical
guy and so i look at patterns and i see
where things are going and people are
always
unfortunate a lot of people just look
right in front of them right it's really
hard to see a couple steps ahead right
but if you logically look at something
you can clearly see where it's going i
said look first of all television has
these massive costs
online video
you saw that had no gatekeepers and no
overhead costs so or very little
overhead costs i'm like that means
there's going to be a million of them
and they're going to start to get more
and more popular and they're going to
serve the audience because they don't
have advertisers they have to serve the
audience first the problem with tv and
i've been in tv pitch meetings is that
they serve advertisers first so i'll be
in a tv pitch meeting and they'll say
okay what's walmart going to think it is
and i think okay this show's doomed
because walmart wants vanilla they do
not want
interesting programming at all overseas
they don't want fights no bickering just
nothing
no drama and by the way do they say that
to the
actual company like will they say this
is the kind of talent we're looking for
if you got a guy like this will
advertise during this time
well it's it's not about talent it's
about the shows so now now we're fast
forwarding a little bit right so when
i'm when i'm taking a tv pitch meeting
now we're in the middle of my career and
we're trying to pitch something from tyt
network to one of the tv stations and so
at that point they're not talking about
talent as much as the content of the
show what kind of show is it right and
so the minute you start talking politics
they're like whoa everybody's out yeah
everybody's out nobody wants it because
they live in the old world in the whole
world you're going to get 100 of the
audience 100 of the market you don't
want to offend anyone it's 1955. it's
okay there's only three tv stations you
put it on you shove your product down
their throats it's going to be fine
legacy media
media you know legacy advertisers by the
way
right now still the same thing i mean
it's not nearly as bad but unbelievable
i just read an article in digital just a
couple of days ago about how the brands
are still like whoa out of this
newfangled youtube thing i don't know
like you know just now yeah and there's
still advertising on tv there's no under
45 year olds on tv at all zero zero zero
zero right and and brands are killing
themselves they're just i i said on
twitter you're better off burning the
money in publicly because at least
people will watch okay nobody's going to
watch you on tv
and so look we have 24-hour channels and
we're on the new tv those ott platforms
right what don't they understand yet is
it just an old-school way of thinking
they don't want to give up what they had
what is it the advertising industry is
the single most conservative industry in
america and i don't mean politically i
mean just by nature so
and and one of the quotes was well
nobody's gotten fired doing this in the
last 20 years buying tv well that's the
problem you should all get fired you if
you're
a brand trying to appeal to younger
viewers
and you're on television and not online
everyone in your marketing team should
be fired
so you're just nuts if you're doing that
you're just burning the money
here's a question for you here because
uh what it makes me think about is the
fact that
you know how justin bieber was found
where did usher find bieber on you
youtube or something like that some
story i don't know if you familiar with
this or not it was or even it was
scooter bronc uh scooter braun found him
and then he teamed up with us sure they
did even the guy from
uh what is that don't stop believing is
that journey yeah okay journey they
brought a filipino guy from the
philippines who was yeah you know he's
like this guy's got the sickest voice he
becomes the lead singer for
you know during a journey and they found
him on youtube
who would logan paul been 20 years ago
who would have a lot of these guys been
20 years ago like literally i'm
wondering like a lot of these guys that
are big vloggers today big youtubers
today who would they have been 20 years
ago
yeah i know maybe they would have gone
on to mtv somehow uh and that would have
been the route that makes sense probably
but i'll tell you what guys
another reason why online video is
always going to win is because
um there's just
too many of them since there's no
gatekeepers the audience is going to
find what they like so it democratizes
media so look i'm not a big fan of logan
paul but you put them on
and people there's a community that's
gonna say hey i like that guy okay
before you couldn't get past the
gatekeepers so the only people that were
allowed on were people that the
executives liked
so who do the executives like well they
like relatively rich people who say that
the status quo is great and you
shouldn't change anything and remember
we're doing a show for walmart so keep
it vanilla that's why tv was doomed the
most boring stuff on
in the world what they're doing
a domino show now i think
i mean they're watching domino's fall i
mean it's just sad yeah they're gonna do
finally the last tv show is just gonna
be bingo
[Laughter]
so but if you i mean if you think about
it again capitalism wins innovation wins
again because they were able to compete
against the traditional guys and the
traditional guys who don't want to do
any work and they're kind of bullying
the talent and saying you better do this
or else
now there's so much competition that you
can't do that anymore because yeah the
reality of it is the talent's going to
find a place to get their voice heard
this the market we're living in you
can't silence people today well some
people are trying to side with certain
people but all i'm saying is if the
talent is a real talent he's going to
make it or she's going to make it if
they go and do the work that they that's
necessary let me bring up a quick point
with tv i want to get your thoughts on
this the other day with your dad
and we were looking for
the the march madness game
you're talking about the legacy media it
used to be three channels the big three
abc nbc cbs and i remember whatever was
the late 90s early 2000s and all of a
sudden it was like 50 channels it's like
holy moly
i'm with pat's dad who's seventy nine
about to be eighties
god bless you gabriel
um
and we're looking for the game and
there's 900 channels he's like oh yeah
yeah i think it may be on 847. maybe
it's on uh 140 like he knew the channels
he knew what was going on or the sports
how many of those do you really watch
that's what i'm saying is that like it's
so fractured you talk about the
democratization of media how does that
factor into that i mean there's so many
tv channels it's no longer a big three
what are your thoughts on that yeah so
real quick couple of things there um
number one
uh
yes because of the fracturing you will
not get the big three again you will get
relatively large companies vox buzzfeed
us right um but there'll be a lot more
talent spread out and they can't nobody
can stop that so you're not gonna get as
you're not going to get seinfeld or er
like shows where 25 30 million people
are watching at the same time that's
like when everyone tuned into dallas for
the finale and you got 100 million
people like that doesn't exist anymore
probably not there's going to be some
tentpole events super bowl
oscars kind of etc and new ones will pop
up uh but so that uh that's one of the
small downsides because then we're we
don't share the same culture anymore if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]